President Reif:
Online learning has
become an indispensable
tool, not just for university
students and professionals, but
for anyone who wants to learn.
Over the past decade, the
immensely talented MITx team
has helped shape
that experience.
Sanjay Sarma: Our
education is going
through an extraordinary
transformation right now,
and MIT is making a statement
to the world through MITx.
And MIT is also transforming
itself through MITx.
Eric Grimson: The fact
that you can get access
to MIT-quality courses if you've
got internet connection is just
an incredible impact.
Ana Bell: The only thing that
matters is a desire to learn,
and it's never
too late to start.
Krishna Rajagopal: It's
an extraordinary learning
opportunity for millions
of independent learners
openly available to anyone,
anywhere, anytime, any place.
Eric Grimson: There are more
learners around the world that
have completed
successfully a course
than we have living MIT alumni.
That's broadening our reach in
a way that just is striking.
Aditya Joshi: Online
learning opens up
the opportunity to engage
with people around the world.
Meghan Perdue: All these people
can come to the same course
with different goals, interests,
and levels of engagement
and find what
they're looking for.
And that's pretty magical.
Sanjay Sarma: On MITx
you can experiment.
You can put in simulations, you
can put in a game, a drawing
program, and it has
helped the world
recognize the value of online.
It's great that MIT
took a lead 10 years ago
to make this happen.
Mary Ellen Wiltrout: We
didn't know 10 years ago
that understanding what
MRNA is would become
a common conversation, but
our courses can help people
with that understanding.
From deciding a major in
a specific discipline,
to applying to a new job,
to truly living the concept
of lifelong learning
during retirement.
You invest in yourself
by learning something
you could not have otherwise,
and a success could literally
change your life.
10 years of MITx is a testament
to how important education
is at any level.
Krishna Rajagopal: We're in the
10th year of MITx version one,
but just at the very beginning
of the MITx for the future.
And that's what makes things
so exciting at this moment.
Eric Grimson: I've been
stopped in airports,
in hotel lobbies by people
who say, I took your course
and it changed my career path.
It's not just me, but
that's other people
offering MIT courses.
You're changing people's lives
in a really positive way.
That's both the excitement
and the spirit of MITx.
President Reif MITx,
congratulations
and happy anniversary.